on this morning's dish Final Four
edition from the host city of
Minneapolis thousands of basketball fans
have descended on the Twin Cities for
this weekend's games and some may be
looking for a good place to eat I'm sure
they are well Dana visited with one of
the hottest chefs in town Dana tell us
about her yeah the lucky fans around
here are visiting restaurants run by
Chef and Kim she's made a name for
herself by taking the distinctive
flavors of her Korean heritage and
applying them in some unexpected ways
tell me about where we're sitting yeah
so this is young Joanie
if you come to eat here it's a
culmination of my palate what I love to
eat I think you can really feel what my
heart and soul is it doesn't take long
to cook I know I bet chef Anne Kim's
heart and soul at young Joanie is part
DNA part ingenuity this is a sampling of
what we offer here at young Joanie and
the things that I chose is really a
reflection of my upbringing the dishes
include pork belly song the Korean
weren't for rash sometimes it gets a
little mess I would say I've completely
overstuffed Korean barbecue short ribs
we grill it on our woodfired grill add
chimichurri and on the base of it is a
charred scallion creme fraiche and pizza
with beef topped with go-to Jeong
vinaigrette salad help yourself
through her food and Kim tells personal
stories this is a childhood favorite of
mine my mother used to stick Japanese
sweet potatoes in our fireplace when we
were little and we take him out of the
coals unwrap them and eat them like
candy and I loved that treat Kim
immigrated to the United States in the
late 1970s when she was just four years
old it's really my maternal grandmother
who raised us because both my parents
worked sort of graveyard shifts I was
always by her side when she was cooking
I always wanted to help I always wanted
to stir the pot when something was
boiling and it was just a part of my my
upbringing growing up she says she was a
class clown her parents worked multiple
jobs and wanted a better life for her as
a doctor or lawyer for college
Kim headed to New York City
when I got into Columbia I thought okay
the parents are good with that but my
ulterior motive was I was gonna start
acting and someday my name would be up
in lights and I'd be on Broadway and so
ironically I got my headshots done in
New York and I moved back to Minneapolis
and I started an eight-year acting
career back home Kim appeared in
productions ranging from Shakespeare's
Othello to promotional videos hello
everyone and welcome to dream date but
she got tired of the uncertainty of
acting when in 2007 her boyfriend now
husband Conrad laugher lost his job in
finance I was looking to make a change
he suggested Kim open a restaurant
I'm the risk-taker and my job was
basically to push an over the over the
cliff I tend to like jump in and then
freak out after I mean that's what he
did for the majority of his life is he
kind of made that Sun yeah on the market
and things and me I played it safe Kim's
first idea was to open a franchise of
the sandwich chain Jimmy John's and
that's what I thought I was going to do
until a lawyer that we hired said during
this whole meeting you never once talked
about your excitement for this Jimmy
John's but how some day you hope that to
open up this intimate family like
restaurant and in good faith I can't I
can't do this for you so he said you
should reconsider doing your own thing
Kim missed New York Pizza and wanted to
bring it to Minneapolis she began
reading books on baking before studying
in San Francisco under Tony Gemignani
13-time world Pizza champion you hear
that crunch after Kim and laugher walked
their dog Lola by an empty convenience
store in 2009 they knew where they would
open their first restaurant they emptied
their savings and maxed out their credit
cards to open pizzeria Lola this is the
only restaurant we actually worked in
yeah scheduled on the line Conrad was a
hoax yeah I promoted myself out of that
job when we opened it was pretty much
all hands on deck and and made pretty
much every pizza yeah it was a lot of
work there's a lot of hours there was a
lot of fun a little more than two years
later they opened hello Pizza a New York
style slice shop like Kim remembered
from college but their most ambitious
project is young Joanie named after each
of their mothers the roughly 7,000
square foot restaurant includes a back
bar speakeasy modeled after lay furs
family cabin in North Dakota creativity
has always driven me to me I just left
one stage the theater stage for another
stage Kim the aspiring actress turned
professional chef was recently named a
semifinalist for the James Beard Awards
after being a finalist one year ago they
call it the Oscars of food so if I
wasn't gonna get that Oscar on the stage
or behind the screen I was gonna get it
you know hopefully get it somehow all of
those things are really really nice and
it's an honor but it's really about the
people that fill the seats and love what
we do all right now I'm craving in Kim's
pizza